ow what's up your boy bobby schneider
these are my favorite snacks
[Music]
slide men
slide
boom
this is my first favorite snack i used
to eat this back back in the days
[Music]
it was milk
some almond milk from almond milk from
ice you want to make some iv slapping up
back in the days i was a little bad kid
when i was like 12 years old eleven
let me take me doing now
selling crap i do a lot of bad stuff
nice to be hungry at night
man
they give us this with some milk
and i had a whole bunch of these racked
up with smokers like a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich
i had a whole bunch of them racked up so
i go to bathroom smoke i like 13 i mean
i'm going in smoke and come back dip
these in the milk and cookies
[Music]
[Laughter]
you can't make this [ __ ] out right
it's is [ __ ] you can't buy baby i'm
sorry
next up we got the fruit snacks now you
got to have my fruit stacks you know i'm
saying fruits gotta have my vitamins
i can't do this i
go freaky why suck me [ __ ]
oh baby
it make your breath smell good i fell in
love with these snacks
this is sad i fell in love with these
nights because he's like the only things
on commentary and reconciling they had a
little vitamin b the vitamin c vitamin b
oh your fruit right there
you know i bust these down
[Laughter]
that is
this right here is very important to me
my favorite chips is i was a little
badass kid on the corner i remember i
was four years old on the corner a nice
chill with all the big guys and i had no
teeth nice and tender give me some money
so i can buy some food they take me get
chicken and doritos
and
i'll be like this on the corner all the
time
[Music]
all right right young corner
so i'm four years old
all right sleep inside my mouth and then
i have all these things on my wife
beating my mama whipped my ass
these are memory doritos i love them
ever since i was four
[Music]
are you funny how you tell me you'll
never eat no cheese you don't like them
cheeses this is all that mama had in the
closet for these kids cheese nuts and
ritz i'm saying i still bust down some
cheese get a little pack of this
my mom should pack using my bag when i
was a kid oh cheating it's rich in the
um lunchables but i ain't really like
the lunch [ __ ] like you gotta eat
that what you want to bring i'm like
give me rice and pizza knock still so
you keep getting rice and pizza alex
tell you in first grade take you out to
school all right the pizza dogs
but she'll pack these and it'll be all
good oh
pineapples pineapples i don't know where
to start from
[Music]
all right
[Music]
i love fruits i love healthy shape [ __ ]
this kind of sounds sound crazy
but
the way
the way she feels in my mind
i mean
voice is juicy
she's
she's very boys she's very boys guys
you know it keeps you hydrated it'll
find out what keeps you hydrated
and she says i think it makes you taste
good
foul play it's good it's healthy and
that's why i like pineapples
it's a bad man
oh
[Music]
now i love plums
my grandmother
my grandma rp her soul she's my favorite
person anytime she come back from church
we'd be bad ass kids running around
brother she should come back with all
her bags she's like hurry up carry this
upstairs
we carry all the clothes all the bags
upstairs
or we help our pack
she have a whole bunch of these shits we
used to steal these shits out the fridge
they get you like yo y'all take two
three each we'll be taking like four or
five of them [ __ ]
oh dear the whole handful
run down the stairs get smacked
go back upstairs eat some more fruits
but that's my grandmother used to bodies
and we used to love it she said i had to
hide it from everybody in the house this
is like our favorite thing in the house
plums
peanuts
like easiest proteins quick it's fast
you get them anywhere
that's my guy key
get my [ __ ] peanuts
the quickest fastest protein
so you got that workout haha
yeah i mean
next snack
is bunny cheese
ginger spring
my grandma
let them say i was a bad kid say all you
need bread on thing and these carbs you
want to get like a nice perfect square
it's cheese and bread so like
that's what they eat back in jamaica
because they couldn't afford too much
[ __ ] so they'll take like a big thick
piece of cheese and they'll make like a
a solid bread with like all types of
flavors in it the bread got like raisin
flavored uh
cinnamon
the bread tastes like flavor you could
eat the bread by itself
they put the cheese with that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that
slap early in the morning
ready for spliff
but
jamaica was a poor people food
then [ __ ] got rich and still
eat it
because as you know [ __ ] the craziest
creatures come from the craziest places
i'm saying just fall in love with it
after you eat it
[Music]
ah so she wanted to say you already know
the run they shh
it's your boy bobby and thank you for
watching my all my favorite snacks now
y'all better have that write it down
and y'all go check out my new project
bad boy independently is dropped or on 1
rpm it's everywhere you can find on all
dsps make sure you type in the whole
bobby schmurder and go check that bot
boy
[Music]
you